all right Christopher hi Christopher
where'd you grow where are you from
um I grew up in Chino California
suburb of La yeah tell me about your
family uh mother and father married
divorced mother moved out to
[Music]
um Rialto father still lives in Chino so
that's where I reside right now with him
oh with your dad yeah how old are you
45. I just had a birthday yeah living
with your dad I live with my dad at 45
yeah
what were you like in high school what
kind of kid
um a little bit anti-social I grew up in
um mid 90s so
uh listen to a lot of Grunge music
Nirvana Pearl Jam Soundgarden sure that
type of stuff
how would you describe your childhood in
general good I would describe it really
good no traumatic very low not very much
to speak of
so you're currently working it's
important shop clerk yes
tell me about that how long you've been
doing that been doing it for the past 16
years 16 years yeah
you got to have some interesting stories
I have plenty of interesting stories
that will hopefully one day manifest
itself into something great
this is probably an audience for
everything there is I mean every time I
think about it it's like remember
um there was customers that would ask me
um I bet you have a lot of story I said
yeah I do because I should write them
down I was like
maybe I will
what kind of customer comes into a porn
shop everybody
the thing with this place is that
it is not
it's not just one person it's a vast
variety of people I get everybody in
that place it's like the U.N of porn
stories it's I would think it's 99 male
um yeah I will have the occasional
females do walk in there and it is
it could be a little bit bothersome
sometimes because some of the male
customers will try to head up on some of
the female customers and that's when
sometimes I have to intervene like
please don't harass the customers are
you just selling
books magazines videos or is there oh
there's other stuff we have a theater
room a private viewing room and an
arcade
so do you have women working there yes
oh you do so yeah you have what kind of
activities going on
um
well uh when you say working there like
you mean working in the booth area
no no no
no
um we have clerks that are female that
work there yes but nothing that is um
like that right
um
so a guy will come in buy a magazine
leave or is there sometimes
um I have we haven't sold magazines in
almost over a year I think
apprent is dead practically almost right
I saw a lot of DVDs DVDs still sell
and everybody always asks me
do people still buy DVDs yeah people
don't want to have
a connection to their pouring directly
towards their computer or their cell
phone they don't want their wife to find
out their boyfriend their lover or
whatever so
they keep it on hand as a um detachment
and that's really what this place is
it's a Detachment from your regular life
so
it's something I learned in when I used
to work for Starbucks
uh third place environment that's
basically what we are
you guys will come in there
that are probably you know married
single everything right yeah these are
guys that probably can't get a female to
yeah interact with them the way you want
or mail it's really funny because we are
not designated as a gay cruising spot
but
um
it's just it's everybody in there
I did I get gay straight transgender
um Everybody did you sell to a gay
audience as well yeah oh you do yeah we
have a huge gay audience we have a huge
transgender audience
really yeah so you have different
departments for different yeah grounds
what's the craziest some what are some
of the things you've seen happen in your
shop I was thinking about this actually
when I was coming I was like
we talk about Andy
Andy lamelli
um he passed away a couple of years ago
he was a former graveyard employee and
one of my best friends
and one day he was doing the janitorial
work because we had run the janitor had
either left or got fired I forgot what
it was but he um he was taking over the
bathroom Duty one day and um
that bathroom is like the third ring of
hell
it is awful but um
uh
he was going in there he was cleaning it
and he said you won't believe what I
found in the tank so the upper tank of
the toilet it's like yeah there's a
giant dildo up there and I was like what
we both went back there and somebody had
taken this huge phallusk and put it in
the tank and had rubber bands tied to
the bottom of it
do not know to this day who it belonged
to
but it's gone now
one of the more humorous Moments One of
the more terrifying moments would be
when a guy walked in there with a gun
and Charlotte a couple of rounds and the
parking line took off do not know what
his problem was
you get a lot of interesting people
coming in there oh yeah
I get guys who drive Teslas BMWs
guys who make millions of dollars it's
really funny when you meet a millionaire
who's completely miserable with their
life and I was sometimes I think about
that I said you have all this money and
you can't find happiness
and they come there for their happiness
they come there for their excitement and
I get that
a lot of people I have a huge homeless
crowd that would show up every once in a
while
too
so you have these homeless guys and you
have these guys who make a lot of money
and then you could have some interesting
moments
but somebody's coming in they're driving
a Tesla or a BMW why do you think
they're coming oh they're into the
corner shop they're coming there to get
their kicks
I really believe that there's something
lacking in their life that they have to
come there and they can't interact with
a
partner yeah
I've seen bondage couples roll into that
place I have seen
regular couples the couples do like you
guys are swingers you don't even look
like swingers or whatever whatever a
typical swinger looks like
um
what's the most disturbing thing you've
seen at the shop
um one time I saw
um these two kids and when I say kids
I'm saying 20 somethings
18 19 I do check IDs and um I think they
were like 19 and 20 and uh these two was
boy and a girl walk in and they said um
have you seen an older Mexican gentleman
walking here I was like I see a lot of
older Mexican gentlemen you got to be
more specific
mustache tall like I don't remember
seeing that guy and they said we saw us
we've seen his car here I was like
okay what do you what are you getting at
and like can we get a ticket for the
back I was like all right it's five
dollars each so they pay their five
dollars to go back there fine
they're looking for somebody
this is one of those situations where I
just don't know how to handle it
yeah my boss wants me to get the money
all right I get that they go back there
I hear a screaming Screech
and then all of a sudden I see this very
well-dressed Mexican Slenderman like a
little mustache kind of like
um Zapata
looking kind of guy tall and he has one
girl on one arm and one boy on the other
and she's screaming at him in Spanish my
Spanish isn't that great
but from what I could gather
what are you doing here what about Mom
what about the family I was like oh damn
this guy just got busted by his kids
I hadn't seen him since that then that
moment and from that moment it just it
really Disturbed me on how they found
him through his app in his phone
and what I tell everybody make sure you
turn off your apps because people are
looking
is it a stressful job for you it can be
it can be if it's not coming from the
management it's coming from the
customers it's not coming from the
customers it's coming from the higher up
in some way but what's what's a
what are the Unseen
stressors in in a job like working at a
porn shop unseen stressors
um
well I think it would have to come down
to
um
trying to um
keep an eye on everybody
and that's like
probably one of the hardest ones to do
and making sure people aren't jumping
into the arcade without paying their
their fee to go the arcade or jumping
back to the um private viewing booths or
trying to get into the arc the theater
room and these are all different these
all cost something different to get into
there's there's a lot of sexually
deviant Behavior
the whole place of the sexual deviant
Behavior what are you talking about I
guess yeah it's um it doesn't matter
um uh it's
sexual addiction is just the addiction
of trying to get the
um
what is it the serotonin the the high
and so these people are looking for
their High I get that I mean I uh you
wouldn't believe how many times I heard
a glass pipe break in the back
or found a a heroin syringe or
dare I see a giant cucumber and a condom
it's um
it can be pretty nerve-wracking your
tree it's a juggling act you're watching
this part you're watching that part
you're watching the register you're
you're making sure nobody steals off the
wall
um does the seediness of it all get to
you no uh I
the thing with me is that I kind of like
the seediness in a way like walking down
here it's like I didn't feel like
totally stressed out walking down in
this area I know this area in some way
um me and La haven't had the greatest
relationship
um but it's um it doesn't bug me because
I know these people in some way
I've been in this situation where I've
hung out with people like this and
they're just people they just want to be
your advice is similar to these
um
a little bit not really I mean I'm not a
guy who likes to smoke the Pookie or
wants to shove a needle on my vein but
grass mushrooms beer alcohol whatever
yeah
um lesser of the evils I've never been a
fan of putting a speck in my van or any
of those drugs what uh what have you
learned about human behavior human
nature human nature about people from
doing this John people just want to be
listened to people just like to talk
they want somebody they're they're
looking for a connection in some way
some people are looking for that for
sexual other people are just looking for
hey how was your day good how are you
doing some people don't seem to have the
capability
to talk
and I get that we are almost conditioned
After High School to get the job and
continue going through our life and
make money for somebody else when we're
just trying to get by and that's why I
get all these most of these people
they're just trying to get by like
everybody what do you think we're all
looking for they're all looking for is
is it love is it connection is it I
think it's a mixture everybody's
different everybody I uh the rich guy is
probably looking for a younger lad being
if he's gay or straight
um the straight guy when I say straight
guy it's it's kind of funny because
he'll go back there stick his dick in a
glory hole and then
you don't know who's on the other end
sometimes there's a woman
sometimes there's not
so it's like whenever anybody says it
tells me that they're straight I can't
give them the side of like really
you're here and you're straight
okay
I'm not judging I'm just I find that a
little bit odd
what do you think
do you think these are Disturbed people
any in any way or is it are they just
lonely
um without finding it not without any
outlet for a better
with funny happiness I think um some of
them are I do believe some of them are
because there is a sadness
that I feel sometimes when I'm there
that is very disturbing
the um being somewhat of an empath I
could I could feed I could feel people's
sadness and then I walk through the door
like oh damn here's another soul
here's somebody who's really down on the
luck and they're sometimes they're just
guys getting off the freeway and they're
just they need that that moment to
decompress and they want to decompress
before they get to their house or before
they get to their wife or wherever
they're going
and this the where the store is located
it's I don't want to give out too much
information but you can see it from the
freeway and that's all I'm going to say
and you think I would think that they
could find it like if a guy wants a girl
to interact with
on any yes way that's that's easily
found no yeah
um there is message boards people
connect with on there
and um not on the not not associated
with the store
but there is a message board that people
talk of about the store that I found out
about so I would go through the message
board seeing what they're saying about
us at the store at the shop
fat guy's working today
fat guy with house working today
handsome fat guy I'm like well thanks
they must be talking about me
I get that every once in a while
sometimes I'll talk about the girls that
are working there cute chick working
today bad chick with attitude I'm like
okay I know what they're talking about
being a female working there must be
tough yes
um my friend Chloe who still works there
um she's still working there and um she
oddly enough she's pretty badass and
she's very quiet but she will not
tolerate anything she she's pretty cool
actually I really like her
she's got to be tough oh yeah that'll
mess with her
yeah to be a female and work at that
place you have to have a strong skin
because the guys the the the way the the
place is set up is that you have a
counter space the door counter space and
then leads all the way to where the
arcade is at and the arcade guys can
look directly out to where the people
are walking in so you get a couple of
look you lose in the booth and they're
like looking like okay who's walking in
or they'll they'll be in the hallway and
then you can see them with their member
out whacking It Off
at you while you're at the counter
you know how many disturbing times I've
had that happen to me
how is this job changed I mean you've
worked there a long time how has it
changed your
the way you see 90 to 90 percent of your
customers are male so how does it change
how you've seen men
um
it doesn't
it's like perverts in one way or another
yeah we all have we all have a kink I
think we all have like some guys have
the school girl thing some guys like um
uh Burly men are I mean it's all
different types so there's something for
everybody something for everybody yeah
non-judgmental my whole thing about the
place is
not to be judgmental of anybody's um
sexual orientation or sexual desires
as long as you're not doing it to a
child
it's cool
consenting adults but
I did have a moment where a guy walked
in the store said where's your little
girl porn I like oh she's
oh Jesus get out now
just leave I don't want to see you I
don't want to talk to you leave
that was a disturbing moment
how's this job impact your
personal your
your life personally I mean do you have
a girlfriend wife uh single actually a
single divorced
the way I look at love I don't really
I'm perplexed by it in a lot of ways I
thought I knew what love was then I
realized I don't know [ __ ]
and then I'm just trying right now I
just staying single and real valuating
everything I think I know and how I
perceive myself and how I perceive the
person I may want to attract in my life
do you believe in true love
yes
but not for myself right now I believe
in it for other people the soul mate
twin flame whatever you have if if
that's what you want to believe in go
for it I believe that you could find it
but for me right now I can't I can't
deal with the idea of somebody falling
in love with me or
be it if I even fall in love with
somebody else again it's
um
at 45 I'm like
I'm I'm done playing games
you want to play games go away it's got
a lot to do with loving yourself yes and
that's what I'm trying to do right now
since I I've suffered from depression
most of my life
um
trying to love myself now is probably
the most key thing I can do yeah
I think anyone can do yeah and um that's
basically what I've been trying to do
and if you can learn to do that you can
be happy without a partner and once you
get there then you become very
attractive to all kinds of Partners
there you go ironically the irony
Christopher what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
never judge a book by its cover
it's it's really funny
because you see some people walk into
that shop and they're all dirty messed
up and you think wow this guy's a bum
you realize that guy is not a bum that
guy works really hard for his money
and he makes a damn good living
so just because the guy walks into your
store wearing a suit and tie doesn't
mean jack [ __ ]
so yeah never judge a book by its cover
all right Christopher thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you wish
you the best of luck thank you thank you